So today we're going to be talking about
domain adaptation and we'll get into
what that means as well as a few
different algorithms for doing that and
the goal for the end of the lecture is
to understand different domain
adaptation methods and when you might
use one method versus another method
now
um what is domain adaptation so we've
covered a few different problem settings
in this course
starting with multitask learning where
our goal was to solve multiple tasks
then looking at transfer learning where
we wanted to solve one task after having
previously solved some Source task and
then we also looked at the meta learning
problem statement where our goal was to
solve a new task more quickly or more
efficiently after solving a set of
previous tasks
and today uh and on Wednesday we'll be
talking about domain adaptation and
domain generalization and these are two
problems that end up looking a lot like
transfer learning and meta learning uh
but are somewhat of a special case of
them in some sense
and so in particular uh the goal of
domain adaptation is we want to be able
to perform well on some Target domain
after trading on data from a source
domain
or possibly multiple Source domains
although in this lecture we'll mostly
look at consider one source domain now
um this ends up looking I'm almost
exactly the same as transfer learning
except a really key assumption that
we're going to make is that we're going
to assume that we can access the target
some data from the target domain during
training
uh and so this is referred to as
transductive learning where we have
access to some basically some test data
and there's a few different forms of
domain adaptation which basically
correspond to different kinds of access
to this target domain data
um in the first case we assume access to
unlabeled data from the target domain or
from the target distribution
in the second case we would assume
access to unlabeled and labeled Target
domain data typically the labeled Target
domain data would be much smaller than
the unlabeled data that we have access
to
and in the last case we would assume
access to a small amount of labeled
Target domain data
no um
we're going to focus the most on
unsupervised domain adaptation
problems like supervised domain
adaptation you could actually do pretty
well on just by fine-tuning and with the
transfer learning techniques that we
talked about before
whereas unsupervised domain adaptation
fine-tuning isn't applicable to them
because you only have unlabeled data
from your target domain
now
there's a couple different assumptions
that we're going to make that are fairly
common and this is where we're going to
see some differences from the transfer
learning setup
the first assumption that we're going to
make is that
the source and Target domain
differ only in P of X or different only
in the domain of the function so this is
one way that you can think about what a
domain means
and as a result of this this means that
the conditional distribution of Y given
X is going to be the same for the source
domain and the target domain
um and
another assumption that we'll consider
this very related to this first
assumption is that we're going to assume
that there exists a single hypothesis or
a single function that can achieve low
error on both the source domain and the
target domain
um and so
the um
in many ways you can think of a domain
as a special case of a task
where when we introduce this notion of a
task we thought of it as
basically corresponding to a data
generating distribution over X over y
given X and over the loss and separately
a loss function for that task
and a domain is going to be something
where only P of X differs between the
different domains and Y given X and the
loss function are going to be the same
across the domain
so essentially a domain is a special
case of a task uh and yeah basically
it's going to correspond to different
distributions over X
and
by making this assumption that it only
differs in X and by making the
assumption that we can access some
unlabeled Target domain during training
we're going to be able to do better than
approaches that
um that are designed for multitask
learning or transfer learning because we
can assume that P of Y given X is
staying fixed
now um let's look at a few examples and
this might make this notion of domain
adaptation a little bit more concrete
so one example is maybe our goal is to
detect or classify tumors from slides of
of tissue cells and we tried to
classifier
uh to be able to detect tumors from
these images from one Hospital
and now we also want to deploy that same
model in a different hospital
but the other Hospital might have
different techniques for collecting
these images or maybe they have
different demographics of patients
and as a result uh the images might look
a little bit different between the
source hospital and the target Hospital
now there still exists um like like
doctors can still look at these images
and figure out uh whether figure out
where whether there's a tumor and so
forth and so they still exist a single
function that can predict
um whether or not there's a tumor from
the image
but there's a distribution shift between
um between these two different domains
and in some ways you can well
you can sort of think of these as
different tasks because you're basically
still doing the same task as only P of X
that's changed we'll refer to these as
different domains
as another example maybe we want to be
able to classify how land is being used
and you trained a really good model that
works well in North America and you want
to be able to deploy that model on
another contact continent such as South
America the appearances of buildings of
of plants in that region weather
conditions pollution may be different
between the source region and the target
region and so again this is really the
same task but you have a different
distribution over the images and so P of
X is changing
um and then as one non-image example
maybe we want to classify or generate
text and we trained a model on Wikipedia
and then we want to deploy our model on
papers on archive or on on PubMed uh
because of the differing vocabulary use
and different sentence structure
a model trained on the source domain may
not translate well or transfer well to
the Target domain and
our goal is to be able to basically use
unlabeled data from the target domain in
order to improve performance on that
Target domain
um and so here are basically three
examples but domains could also be
different people or different users it
could correspond to different points in
time
um or uh or different institutions like
data from different schools different
companies or different universities
[Music]
yeah so um there exists some function uh
f of x that achieves a low error on both
the source data set and the target data
set
yeah so the key difference or one key
difference between domain adaptation and
a typical transfer learning problem is
that we have access to Target domain
data during training
um and if we kind of revisit these
assumptions this means that for example
if we want to translate our our text
classifier to Archive uh we might have
access we have access to unlabeled data
on archive already and so
this is going to assume that we we don't
have to kind of directly deploy our
model immediately we can take that
unlabeled data from archive incorporate
that with the training data from
Wikipedia that might be labeled and um
and kind of train a model that we think
should be better at archive in
comparison if we had only trained on
Wikipedia and deployed it directly
um and so there are going to be some
scenarios where it's this assumption is
unrealistic but there's also going to be
a number of scenarios where you can you
do already have access to your unlabeled
data such as such as on archive or maybe
when you are trying to translate it to a
new hospital you do already have data
from that hospital you don't need to
deploy it immediately without any
additional training
domain
yeah so if you have access to label data
a lot of label data from the target
domain then you probably don't need
things like domain adaptation you don't
necessarily need to use any of the
source data because you can just train
directly on your target data whereas if
you only have a small amount of label
data or you have a small amount of
labeled data a lot of unlabeled data or
if you only have unlabeled data that's
where things like domain adaptation can
be very helpful
and then again if we kind of revisit
this hypothesis of their existing or
this Assumption of their existing a
single hypothesis I think that this sort
of assumption is very realistic in in
all of these uh scenarios
um where you can probably kind of just
look at an image and figure out the land
use um if you're uh kind of an expert on
uh what what different buildings look
like and likewise be able to
um be able to predict certain things
from text uh
regardless of where it's coming from
okay any questions on the domain
adaptation problem statement before we
move on
yeah
yeah so you maybe one thing that you're
pointing out here is that you can
trivially say that there exists a single
hypothesis
um
given the identity of the domain
so yeah so if you can identify the
domain X from or the domain D from X
um and assuming that you can get low
error on each of the individual domains
then that assumption trivially holds
there are often scenarios where it is
difficult to identify the domain from
from the input certainly images are
something where it may not be that hard
although
um if you take an image from anywhere on
on the globe I'm not sure if a
classifier would be able to tell exactly
what continent is from
um so there's certainly scenarios where
you can't predict D from X and uh the
stronger assumption Beyond this one is
that uh
is that basically the distribution over
y given X for your Source data is equal
to the distribution over y given X for
your Target data this is a stronger
assumption and most of the approaches
that we'll be looking at today are also
going to make this assumption
cool
um
so we're going to look at three
different algorithms for unsupervised
domain adaptation
and
I guess maybe before I touch on the
algorithms I guess one other thing that
may be worth touching on is
um on Wednesday we're gonna also
consider a variant of this problem where
we assume that we have data from
multiple different domains during
training and our goal is to generalize
zero shot to a new domain
um
that's going to and basically a lot of
the algorithms that we're going to build
up today are also going to be applicable
in that domain generalization problem
setting as well
cool
um
so now let's first start by considering
a toy domain adaptation problem
and in particular our source domain will
be this blue distribution and our Target
domain will be the green distribution
and it's just going to be a binary
classification problem
uh this could correspond to something
like sample selection bias where I when
you collected a data set it wasn't
actually representative of the true
population
and if we have a binary classification
problem maybe it looks something like
this where uh these are examples drawn
from our source distribution
and the bulk of the samples are kind of
in the region where we have high
probability under our under P of s
and um unfortunately one thing that
might come up here is if you have like
if a lot of your data is coming from the
high probability regions of that space
then it may the classifier trained on
that Source data set
May pay very little attention to
examples that have low probability under
the source data set and high probability
under the target data set so these data
points right here
and if it pays very little attention to
those two data points then it may just
learn a very simple classifier that um
that just learns like basically a single
linear decision boundary
um that's kind of able to accurately
classify almost all of the data points
and unfortunately if it does this then
that that classifier if it was actually
evaluated on data from the target
distribution would actually perform
quite poorly when evaluated on that new
Target distribution
uh and so
there's a question of well okay if we
have labeled data from The Source data
set and unlabeled data from the target
data set is there anything that we can
do to learn a classifier that does well
on the green Target distribution
does anyone have any thoughts on what we
might do in this particular example
seriously suggesting that we shift the
the source examples in some way
so how exactly would you do that
um so you've got like your target
examples
which are unlabeled but you know where
we are and you also got your songs for
examples
um
but I guess
you could like just make very big
estimate the mean of the so so we know
where the target examples are we know
that they're kind of on the left hand
side
um and but we don't know what their
labels are and we have access to labeled
source examples as well
um
yeah
what you can do is shift the weights
that's the different examples so you can
do an important sampling are looking
important to be reading yeah so maybe
this is about maybe this is what you're
describing I'm not sure um you can
basically kind of change the weight of
the examples such that you kind of
upweight the examples that have high
probability under the target
distribution especially if they have low
probability under the source
distribution
uh and so kind of the intuition here is
if we up weight these data points and
down weight some of the other data
points then we should learn a classifier
that can more accurately
get a decision boundary that's more
accurate for the target distribution
cool
um so now there's a question of
this is kind of this intuitively I think
makes sense like kind of visually you
can see that if you update those
examples you'll probably learn a
classifier that's more accurate on the
target distribution
uh but there's also a question of why
this makes sense mathematically
uh and so
our goal
um is to
kind of minimize how well we
um how well we do on the target
distribution
this should be X
so our goal is like to minimize
f of x
the loss function
for our function on the target
distribution
with respect to our model parameters now
of course we can't sample from this
distribution directly
but we can sample from our source
distribution and so if we just did
standard empirical risk minimization
um
that would correspond to minimizing with
respect to our our source distribution
of the loss function
now
we know that we can sample from The
Source distribution but our goal is to
to minimize this term right here
and what we can do is if we kind of
expand out this expectation as an
integral uh over the
[Music]
Target distribution of our loss function
then
we know that the we want to be able to
sample from P of s and so we can do a
somewhat similar trick to what we did in
the variational inference lecture and
basically multiply
this by
uh P source of X Y divided by P source
of X comma y this is just equal to one
and so we're just multiplying
everything by one
and
then we can basically incorporate this
into the expectation rather than this
and the expectation and so if we do this
we see that this is equal to the
expectation of under the source
distribution which is what we have
access to
of the
um
of P Target of X comma y divided by P
source of X comma Y
and our loss function
uh and so this is pretty nice because
this means that now we can sample from
our source distribution evaluate our
loss
on those data points but we're basically
going to be waiting the our loss by this
ratio right here and so the data points
that have a high that have a high Target
value and a low Source likelihood are
going to be up weighted and if they have
a high likelihood under the source at a
low likelihood under the target then
they're going to be down weighted
I don't know there's one more step here
which is that if we assume uh this uh
this equality the kind of assumption
that y given X is the same for the two
distributions then we can now replace
this with um with just P of x
and the reason why we can do that is we
know that uh
P of X comma y equals P of x times P of
Y given X and if this is the same then
this is going to cancel out between the
two and we'll be left with P Target of x
divided by P source of x
cool and so this is just written out on
the slides
um
our goal is to basically be able to
minimize the risk on the target
distribution
we can write out that equation as an
integral and then multiply the inside by
one which is the source divided by The
Source likelihood and then evaluate that
and then that ends up being the
expectation under the source data set of
the
of this kind of importance weight here
yeah
the impression behind this very strong
assumption
oh the intuition behind this
um so
the
I guess there I don't think that there's
any
um
particular
I guess there are some problems that
where this is going to hold and there
are some problems where this is not
going to hold
the whole domain then why would for us
for this AMX
[Music]
um
the
if for example you are
um
you are uh I don't know polling people
about their political preferences and
you kind of
uh don't sample very uniformly
um you kind of get a biased sample then
typically if you have good features of a
person
um like they're
like regardless of the person that you
um that you sampled this should stay
fixed
uh but it may be that you just kind of
sampled a you didn't kind of uniformly
sample from the population you wanted to
sample from
uh and so I guess in the problem that
we're looking at here uh we're this is
really and we'll talk about the kind of
the limitations of this approach in a
minute but this is really focusing on
sort of sample selection bias
um but there's also lots of other
examples where this will also hold like
in the kind of the medical imaging
scenario where like a tumor is like
uh you should be able to recognize a
tumor from the image uh and you won't
ever have a scenario where an image from
One hospital
um has a tumor and that same exact image
would be generated but doesn't have a
tumor in another hospital and so
there are a lot of scenarios where this
this can hold if you're kind of
collecting data in certain stairs and
then there are also multitask problems
where it won't hold as well and you want
to these sorts of approaches are only
applicable or primarily applicable when
that does hold
foreign
so this equation
agrees with the intuition that we saw on
the previous slide where we're going to
be up waiting examples with a high
likelihood under the target distribution
and a low likelihood under the source
distribution
now a key question that comes up is how
do we actually compute this weight right
here how do we compute the importance
weight
one thing that we could do is just
estimate these likelihoods like fit a a
generative model
to estimate the likelihood of an example
under the target distribution and
separately fit a derivative model to our
source distribution
but unfortunately it can be fairly
difficult to estimate these likelihoods
accurately and in a way that is
calibrated and consistent with kind of
consistent across the Target and Source
distribution
and so we'd like to be able to estimate
these weights without training a density
model on our Target distribution and our
source distribution
um
and so it turns out there's actually a
way that that you can do that
uh and the Really the key the key reason
why we can get away with doing that is
our goal isn't just to estimate the
target the kind of the density but our
goal is specifically to estimate this
ratio
uh and the reason why we can
um
if we kind of uh there's a way that we
can basically manipulate this ratio to
get something that looks more like a
discriminative something that we can
estimate with discriminative models
rather than with generative models
uh and so specifically
um first we can write out that uh
the likelihood of X under the target
distribution
um this is equal to
the likelihood of x given that the
domain is equal to the Target domain and
writing it out this way is going to just
make things a little bit more clear
and
we can use Bayes rule
to rewrite this as the probability that
the domain is equal to the Target given
X
P of x
divided by
the probability that the domain is the
target domain
and we can like likewise kind of write
out the same exact thing for if the
domain is the source domain
and now our goal is we want to be able
to estimate
the probability that an example
is p of x given
the domain is Target divided by
the probability of x
given that the domain is equal to the
source domain this is our importance
weight
and so if we want to do this we can
basically just take this equation for
the Target and divide it by this
equation for the source
and if we do that
first we'll divide the first term so
this is going to be P of D equals Target
given X divided by P of D equals Source
given X then we'll divide the next term
which would be P of x
divided by P of X and then we'll divide
the last term
which will give us P of domain equal
source and P of domain equals Target
and
this cancels out of course this is just
a constant and so multiplying our loss
function by a constant
doesn't really change anything it
doesn't depend on Theta in any way
um and this term right here
we've now kind of
basically flipped x given Target to now
be uh Target given X and Source given X
and this is something that we can
estimate with the discriminative model
and in particular we can just train a
classifier to be able to predict if an
example came from the target domain or
the source domain
so we'll basically train a classifier to
take his input X
and then it could be whatever sort of
function you want and it's going to tell
you whether or not it thinks it came
from the target domain or the source
domain
um and this will basically give you an
estimate of
uh P of uh Target given X which is going
to be equal to 1 minus
P of source given X
and so then you can use this classifier
to estimate the importance weight right
here
and so specifically what this looks like
is we first used Bayes rule
um to
kind of write out what P of x given the
domain is equal to
and then once we divide our importance
weight out
we get this um
we get the product of a constant and
this term right here which we can
estimate with a binary classifier
also then specifically if we kind of
walk through the algorithm and what it
looks like
the first thing that we'll do is we'll
train this binary classifier
and its goal will be to estimate if an
example comes from the target
distribution or the source distribution
and this is going to operate only on
kind of the input it's not going to look
at the label
then we will resample or re-weight the
data
according to
the kind of importance weight that we
derived right here
which is just you can think of it as
kind of if you're
classifier is estimating the probability
of a source that the X Came From the
Source distribution then it'll just be 1
minus that classifier value divided by
the classifier probability
and then once we either re-weight or
resample our data then we'll optimize
our loss function on the re-weighted or
resampled data
yeah
makes sense when there's a well-defined
source and targeted distribution but
maybe North and South America don't turn
out to be the best two categories maybe
there's some maybe less to think about
it in terms of persuasive variables that
apply and I'm wondering if you are going
to get some generalizing to that
yeah so the question is
um we've been talking about source and
Target distributions and
it may be that
that we don't have these kind of two
clear-cut things
um like two continents like it may be
that like there are some countries in in
North and South America that actually
more like each other than um because
they're actually very close to one other
than than they are in different domains
and so perhaps we could generalize this
by thinking about things like continuous
latent variables and so forth
um
so it's a good question the
we're not going to generalize it
um
in this lecture
um one thing that I'll mention though is
that the re one of the reasons why we we
are defining this in a very clear-cut
way is that we're really defining our
source distribution to be our training
data and our Target distribution to be
the distribution in our test data and so
it could be that your Source
distribution looks something like
like this for example and your target
distribution
um maybe your target distribution looks
something like this for example and it
seems a little bit weird to call these
two different domains because they
actually have a lot of overlap right
here
but
um if you think instead of this as
basically kind of our training
distribution and this as our test
distribution
um that's that's why we're going to
basically Define it as so clear-cut and
the algorithms that we're talking about
here they can take into account that
there is this overlap and they'll still
work well in that scenario
cool
um
I I guess I'm also thinking that there I
mean
there may also be algorithms that you
can derive that to try to kind of take
into account how close together two data
points are
um
we've actually been thinking about
developing algorithms like that um in
some of our research but there aren't
really any
that many mainstream algorithms I think
that take that into account
yeah
we could model the if we could go a bit
of generative side and model the our
district Data Center
so the question is how would this look
like if we could
um estimate the data distribution
um
for Target or for source
so typically I think that if you can
estimate if you can approximate the
densities then you you can just use that
directly rather than training a
classifier I don't know of any way to
combine the two I mean you could combine
the two like if you think that you have
a rough estimate of one and a rough
estimate the other then you could try to
average them or combine them in some
other way but uh
I don't know of
um typically you typically you do one or
the other
um typically this one works like using a
classifier typically works better
because getting good likelihood
estimates is for especially for high
dimensional data is very difficult
yeah
Trying to minimize the loss on the
public distribution
but in general they want to minimize the
voltage P of X not P of x given to equal
to Target
in general you want to do better on all
the samples but I'm just thinking that
even this is okay because you're
assuming 30 of Y given X is the same for
both source and Target so isn't this a
bit of like a problem because
in general
you're only like targeting the content
distribution right in this class
function and you're you don't care about
like performance on The Source
distribution at all in this formulation
yeah so in this population we're really
optimizing for how well we do on the
target data distribution and this is
operating under the assumption that
that the unlabeled data that we have
from the target distribution is
representative of our test data and if
you optimize for this and then evaluate
it on the source data distribution and
you kind of broke that assumption then
this wouldn't work as well as if you
just trained on the source distribution
directly and so this is really assuming
that you are getting an accurate
estimate
um basically that you really have
unlabeled data from your target
distribution rather than some other
distribution and so you can think of
this as sort of like optimizing for a
particular test distribution and and
really trying to specialize the model
for that test distribution rather than
trying to learn a general purpose model
that will work well for any domain and
some of the things that we'll cover on
Wednesday will be actually optimizing
for doing well on basically all the
domains that you've seen so far uh not
just the test domain
foreign
now one thing I'm actually somewhat
surprised hasn't come up yet is that
this is making a
um a pretty important assumption when we
optimize for this and generally when we
take this approach
which is that uh
if you optimize for this quantity
and there's something that has
like zero likelihood under your Source
distribution
uh that's going to be
a little bit of a problem you won't be
able to actually optimize this
effectively
and essentially the assumption that this
is making is that your Source
distribution really needs to cover the
target distribution because if it
doesn't cover the target distribution
especially the parts with high
likelihood then you won't be able to
upweight the the parts with high
likelihood
uh and so more formally if the
likelihood under the target distribution
is non-zero for an input then you need
the likelihood under the source
distribution to also be non-zero you
need to have kind of data from that
region and if you can satisfy this
assumption then you could actually
um
there's actually some kind of uh kind of
theoretical guarantees that you can show
for this kind of method
um and so there are going to be some
scenarios where this might hold in other
scenarios where this may not hold so
um if you for example train on Wikipedia
and your target distribution is archive
or PubMed that might be a scenario where
you may have enough coverage in your
Source data set because Wikipedia does
actually have some pretty technical
content in it
but on the other hand if you have data
only from One Source hospital and you're
trying to generalize to a be able to
make predictions for a new hospital with
um pretty different looking looking
images uh in scenarios like that the
source probably wouldn't cover the
target distribution and as a result
approaches like this wouldn't perform
well
and so this gets into the next two
classes the next two algorithms which
actually can handle scenarios where the
source and target distribution don't
overlap
cool
um so
the um
let's look at another toy example uh
and in particular again we're going to
be trying to learn a binary classifier
and our source distribution will look
something like this
and let's say our Target distribution
looks something like this
uh and we're again going to operate in
this setting where we only have
unlabeled data from our Target
distribution but some of the methods
here can actually also be applied to the
setting where you have labeled data from
the target distribution
now unfortunately if you just train a
classifier on your Source distribution
this wouldn't give you a very accurate
classifier on the target uh the target
domain
uh and as an example problem you could
imagine that maybe your target domain
corresponds to the Eminence data set
where you want to be able to classify
different digits and your target domain
corresponds to a different digit
classification task
in particular these are images taken
from street view of different house
numbers
and you will basically want to take the
classifier that you trained on emness
maybe through a pie torch tutorial and
also apply it to images of house numbers
in order to do this
um
this next class of approaches because we
because there isn't kind of a direct
overlap in the support we can't just
update data points and Eminence that
probably wouldn't work very well on this
problem
but what we could try to do is we could
try to align the features that it has
learned from the two domains in order to
encourage it to have a similar
representation of
um
of the two distributions
and in particular what this might look
like is something where we try to
encourage the feature spaces to overlap
as much as possible
and then if they do overlap as much as
possible and they have the same
distribution then if we train a
classifier only on the source data
then that classifier should perform much
better on the target distribution
now
um
then there's a question of how do we
kind of go about trying to align these
different feature spaces
and I should also mention that
um something like this should work uh
the best when there is kind of a clear
when there is some sort of alignment
between the two distributions
if your two distributions uh kind of
both look like circles
uh and you have just some kind of two
some data points that look like this if
you try to align these two circles you
may not necessarily get a good
classifier by trying to align your
features whereas if your distribution
looks
um something like this and your target
distribution
look something like this there's more of
a clear alignment between these two
distributions and
in that case if you try to kind of align
these two shapes you're more likely to
have something work out and so you can
imagine that something like emness
digits maybe has kind of the zeros are
over here the ones are over here maybe
the nines are over here
and you can imagine that with something
that has a little bit more of an
interesting manifold to the data
distribution it might align more readily
than if you just have like features that
are drawn from like a gaussian a
gaussian space
foreign
so in terms of aligning the features uh
we're going to assume that we have some
encoder that encodes our inputs into
some feature space
these encoders could be just the same
function or they could be separate
functions one for the source and one for
the Target
and really our goal is to try to match
the features that's coming out of these
two encoders but we don't just want to
match them in terms of having them all
be the same we want to match them at the
population level we want basically these
to be to be mapping rather than trying
to just collapse these features into the
same spot and so we can't just apply
like a kind of a an L1 or L2 loss on the
individual features
instead we need to try to figure out how
to match the distributions
and essentially what we want is we want
uh samples from this distribution to be
indistinguishable from samples from the
other distribution of features
and if those samples are
indistinguishable then the distribution
should be the same
yeah
require that um
[Music]
make the alignment work
um so the question was does it mean that
P of S and P of T have to be the same
distribution such as gaussian
distributions so they don't have to be
identical distributions uh and I guess
the but but you do need them to be like
you do want to have them have like a
similar shape
and I guess in the feminist example P of
s corresponds to the distribution over
these emness digits and um
and P Target corresponds to the
distribution of street view house
numbers
the
one scenario in which one example where
that kind of agrees with your intuition
here is that if for example in mnist you
had like 90 of your data set was zeros
and in street view house numbers ninety
percent of your data set was like fives
or something like that
um if you have a mismatch in the label
distribution like that then something
like this probably wouldn't work well
because it wouldn't be able to kind of
find an alignment between the two
distributions uh whereas if the um if
the distribution of like over digits for
example is much more even then you
should be able to align it much more
easily
um and so roughly
you could sort of think of this as the
shape being
um
the shape of the distribution being
somewhat similar but it's okay if like
the distribution is rotated or if it has
a different mean or something like that
um yeah but and I'm not sure if there's
actually a way to former formally
describe this constraint or this
assumption but it is something that is
pretty important for these approaches to
work
cool um and so the key idea in order to
basically try to encourage these samples
to be indistinguishable from each other
is to basically we're again going to
train a classifier that tries to predict
whether or not an example is from a
source domain or a Target domain uh but
this time the classifier is going to
operate on the features rather than on
the inputs and our goal is going to be
to try to learn features that fool that
classifier
such that basically if the classifier
cannot
accurately predict which domain the
features came from that means that the
two distributions over
um over the encoded samples are
identical
so the question was in the circle case
um why is it not possible to kind of
rotate and align the two distributions
um
I in this scenario I if you only have
unlabeled data from your target domain
it's ambiguous how you're how you should
rotate it
um and so that was the main point that I
was trying to make there whereas if you
have a distribution that has more
features to it it will be more clear how
you're supposed to rotate and align the
two
um and so in this example what it would
probably do is it would just try to find
like the easiest or simplest way to to
come to align the two that would be for
example without any rotation and if your
positive examples look like this then
that might end up leading to a poor
classifier
yeah
what does the what does population level
mean uh yeah
he's always not sure
right so
um by support I'm referring to the
assumption that we made uh on the
previous
um
um in the previous case when we were
doing the important tweets we assume
that the support of the distribution of
the source distribution covered the
target distribution and so support means
basically
um the ex the basically the region of
the probability distribution for which
uh the density is non-zero
um
and then
um population level I basically mean
instead of looking at individual trying
to match individual examples we're
trying to match
um kind of the entire population of
examples
or population of features in this case
yeah what ensures that the encoder for
the Target domain does something useful
like it seems like you can satisfy this
objective by just generating random
samples that have nothing to do with the
numbers advantage yeah so um if your
goal was only to fool the domain
classifier uh what it could do is it
could just like output random features
or output all zero features or something
like that and there's nothing
encouraging it to uh actually give you
good features and so what we're going to
do is we're not only going to have this
loss but we're also going to try to be
able to classify the source examples
using the features
examples right
um
so even if you try to classify on the
features
um yeah it could learn a classifier that
works well for the source but not
necessarily for the Target
um
I
think
right so
the there is a question of whether or
not to actually learn have these
encoders separate and the target encoder
could learn something that is pretty
different from the source encoder and so
there is a little bit of a trade-off
like you could learn a single encoder
you could also which would kind of
prevent this issue
um
and if you learn a Target encoder you're
basically hoping that the
um the solution that is kind of the
simplest is the one that Maps them into
a consistent space and if you if you
have a similar architecture and randomly
initialize them uh in a similar way my
expectation is it would give you
something reasonable and it there's kind
of empirical evidence that that supports
that as well
um but you may also it may also be that
you want to actually share some of the
weights between these two encoders
cool
um so
concretely what does this look like so
we're going to be training a feature
encoder that takes his input our example
and gives us features
we're going to be also training a
classifier to predict labels from these
features
and back propagating the kind of
cross-entropy loss with respect to our
label predictions into both the feature
encoder and the label classifier
this corresponds to the standard
supervised learning
what's new is we're also going to be
training a classifier that estimates the
domain that the input came from from the
features of that input
and what we can do is then try to train
the features such that we cannot predict
the domain accurately
and so what this means is that the
domain classifier its goal will be to um
its goal will be to kind of
maximize the accuracy of this classifier
whereas the goal of the features are to
minimize the accuracy of this classifier
and so to do that what we can do is we
can just take the gradient coming from
uh the the loss for the classifier and
negate it and then pass the negative
gradients from the domain classifier
into the feature encoder
um this is called a kind of a gradient
reversal layer where you're basically
just going to be reversing the gradient
before back propping it into the feature
encoder
and so
here we're going to be minimizing label
prediction error and trying to maximize
domain confusion
and if we write out this algorithm kind
of more completely
what this looks like is first we're
going to update
the domain classifier
C or C5 and this is going to be with
respect to basically how accurate is how
accurate that classifier is
which is just denied by LC
and
then we're going to
update
our features
or the encoder f of x
as well as the label classifier
G
and we're updating these with respect to
uh basically how well we're at we're
predicting why
minus the
um the loss function of the classifier
and we have a kind of a coefficient here
to control how much you weight the
classifier loss versus the label
prediction loss yeah how exactly do you
send the negative examples in this case
for the domain classifier since
how do you get Negative examples for the
main classifier so we're assuming uh
like before that we have access to
unlabeled data from the target domain
so the label classifier
um
basically l y is only evaluated on data
from our source data set
and LC is evaluated using both the
source data set and the target data set
foreign
space where the shape should align
um I'm not sure how you would get the
projection to project it into that space
yeah
sounds good and one thing that I'll
mention here is it's important to do
this iteratively so if you first kind of
just train your domain classifier and
then you just kind of fix it and then
train your features to try to fool it uh
at some point it may um you basically
will just change your features such that
they're out of distribution for your
domain classifier and um kind of fool
the domain classifier without actually
having features that are
indistinguishable and so in practice you
need to kind of iterate this process
between updating your domain classifier
and updating your features in your label
classifier and this will ensure that
your domain classifier is always kind of
up to date on the latest version of the
features
cool um so this is written out here we
randomly initialize our encoder label
classifier and domain classifier we then
update our domain classifier which is
just um basically corresponds to Binary
classification between the source
examples and the target examples and so
this is just writing out the cross
entropy loss
and then
um and then we will
update the parameters of our features
and label classifier with respect to the
um how well that it's predicting the
labels as well as this
um
auxiliary term that corresponds to
domain confusion
[Music]
in the third step
you're saying is there any problem with
passing in Target data into
the um
into the domain classifier
so the domain classified will be trained
on both Source data and Target data and
so you can see that right here in step
two where it's trained on both Source
data and Target data and so the target
examples they'll not be out of
distribution for the domain class right
the main class will be trained on them
and so that will give it an accurate
estimate for whether or not those
examples Came From the Source domain or
the target domain and then you'll kind
of reverse the gradient to encourage the
features to produce features that the
domain classifier can't accurately
predict
look in this like this third step is
kind of like uh well holding the
features of
Source data close to Target data
why don't we also like pull the
features of Target data up close to the
Source unit
um so
this loss will be evaluated on both the
source and Target and so it will be
incur like encouraging it to bring the
two together uh and so it's not going to
be bring one to another it will bring
kind of the two together it would
basically just try to find what features
will make it um make it make basically
the in-classifier's job hard
um the first term and the third step
this just corresponds to the like how
accurately we're able to predict the
labels and this is only done on the
source data set because we only have
labels for the source data set
thank you
cool
um now in terms of a couple design
choices I mentioned that you can learn a
separate source and Target encoder this
can give the model a little bit more
flexibility because if the source and
Target images look very different you
might need different filters or
different weights to process them but it
can also possibly give the model too
much flexibility which could lead to
some of the issues that we discussed
um there's also a couple different forms
of of of this of the loss function for
trying to confuse the domain classifier
and this is often referred to as domain
adversarial training
um one of them is what we talked about
with this gradient reversal layer and
this is the same as how generative
adversarial networks are implemented
but another option is instead of trying
to maximize the loss of the domain
classifier you could also try to
optimize for the um basically for the
cost of power to be outputting a 50 50
guess between the two domains
um
and this will be something this will be
kind of optimizing for
um
kind of essentially for it to be to have
kind of basically no idea what the
correct domain is
[Music]
um
and kind of the intuition behind the
second option is that
if you maximize the domain classifier
loss then that corresponds to predicting
Source confidently when it's actually
Target and predicting Target confidently
when it's a source and if you could
actually if you can do that and get the
worst loss of the two that actually
would give you features that can still
distinguish between source and Target
um and so the second option will
somewhat prevent that although in
practice with option one if you're
updating your domain classifier enough
um you should be able to avoid that
issue as well
cool um and then there's a question of
how well does this work so
um we'll look at two different examples
this is a toy example where the source
domain data is shown as the red and
green data points and the target domain
is the black data points
and if you train a neural network in a
standard way only on the source data you
get a decision boundary in the black
line
and we see it as different at these few
different points like here for example
it's incorrectly classifying these data
points as green
um it's likewise incorrectly classifying
these data points as red
in contrast if you use the approach that
we just talked about
this will shift the decision boundary
um to something that looks like this
where it is actually accurately
classifying these data points it also
has kind of shifted the decision
boundary here as well so that you are
you're actually much more accurately
making predictions on the target domain
data
um they also evaluated on the digit
examples that we looked at before and so
they looked at emness to this kind of
synthetic colored eminist version
um the synthetic numbers to street view
house numbers street view house numbers
to mnist and these um
signs to these uh German uh traffic
signs
and if you compare training only on the
source data set to this approach you see
that you can get a really substantial
Improvement in performance often kind of
as much as almost 20 in some cases uh
and it doesn't do as well as if you were
to train on label data from the target
distribution but it is able to bridge
the gap
um fairly significantly in a number of
different cases
cool um so to summarize this part uh
these sorts of methods are fairly simple
to implement and they can work pretty
well like we saw on the previous slide
they don't require
The Source data to cover the target
distribution which is pretty nice
it does involve an adversarial
optimization which sometimes can be a
little bit tricky and you you really
need to tune this uh this weight right
here to kind of trade off the
indistinguishability of the features and
the um your accuracy on the source
domain
it also like we discussed requires some
some degree of clear alignment in the
distributions of the data and if those
distributions are very different it may
be difficult for the algorithm to figure
out how the two domains align in
practice
cool
um and then the last class of methods
that we'll look at
um is uh it's also going to be somewhat
trying to find an alignment but instead
of trying to learn a feature space that
is perfectly aligned it's instead going
to try to learn a mapping from one
domain to the other domain
and really the key idea here is if we
could translate from examples from one
domain to another domain then we would
be able to do pretty well on the target
data set so if you could translate
source examples to Target examples then
you could just basically translate your
labeled Source data set into your target
domain and train a predictor on the
translated data set and then deploy your
predictor on the target examples
likewise if you were able to translate
from Target to Source then what you
could do is train a predictor on your
Source data set and then translate your
test example your target example to the
source domain with your um with your
translator and then evaluate the
predictor on the translated examples
and one key difference between these
approaches and the previous approaches
is we're actually going to be operating
in the original input Space X rather
than operating on features
then of course the question comes up is
that how do we actually go about
learning to translate between these
different domains
so
the first thing that you could do is
train your model f that's translating
bits from source to Target to generate
images from your target distribution
and likewise train a function G to be
able to generate images from your Source
distribution
and you can do this with uh with a
generative adversarial Network where
you'll be trading another a classifier
to be able to predict if something came
from the source domain or the target
domain and then your goal is for your
generative model to be able to fool that
classifier and think that the data that
it's generating came from uh the domain
that you're trying to
um trying to generate from
and so kind of what this looks like is
if you have some uh kind of source
distribution that looks like this
and you have another Target distribution
that looks like this
essentially what you're going to be
trying to do is train something that
takes an example from your Source
distribution and translates it into your
target distribution this is going to be
a function f
and this function f will take us input
The Source example and it'll be trained
with the Gan to generate examples that
look like the target distribution
and likewise you'll also be training a a
function G to take his input an example
and map it to an example from The Source
data set
and one of the nice things about this
objective is it doesn't require you to
have any paired data you don't need to
know
um kind of what example specifically
corresponds to the other example we're
just going to be training this
generative model to generate samples
that look like they came from the target
set
um that said if you only do this
objective you'll run into a bit of a
problem which is that
uh it won't necessarily learn to
um learn data learn to map in a way
that's like somewhat consistent between
the different domains
uh in particular if if F maps from here
to here
there's nothing that's stopping G from
mapping from here to over here to
mapping to something completely
different
and so there's one additional objective
that we can incorporate into this
approach that tries to actually optimize
for the consistency of these two kind of
domain translators
and in particular what we're going to
try to do is we can take a data point
from our source data set map it from F
and then map it back with g
and basically try to
encourage the distance between the
original data point and the data point
after going through this cycle to be
very small
and so we're basically going to kind of
minimize this distance
right here
and so this is um
trying to address the fact that the
mapping is under constrained and it can
be kind of an arbitrary mapping
and
we're basically going to be encouraging
the models to learn this kind of
consistent by objective mapping by
training them to be sickly cyclically
consistent such that if you map from one
domain and back it gives you a data
point that's very similar to the
original data point and likewise if you
go from Target to source and back to
Target you want to get back the same
data point as before
and so the way that you can implement
this is uh
basically just with a kind of a standard
L1 or L2 objective where you sample a
data point from your Source data set map
it to Target and then map it back to
source and then compare that that
example after the cycle to the original
example and encourage them to be similar
to one another
and so that's what that's how we get
this loss function right here
uh and so then the full objective uh for
this approach will be we're going to be
training f and g uh F will be kind of
trained to generate examples that look
like Target examples
G will be trained to generate examples
that look like the source and then we'll
have this additional regularizer that
encourages uh cycle consistency which
says that when you kind of form a cycle
you should get back to where you came
from
any questions on how this works
so if you take this approach and apply
it to data sets from different domains
and so for example if you take a data
set of
Monet photos or Monet paintings and a
data set of photos you can get something
that maps from basically can take a kind
of a painting from Monet and translate
it into a photo and likewise take a
photo and translate into something that
looks like a painting from Monet
um likewise you can take a data set of
pictures from the summer and translate
it to something that looks more like
winter
and and the reverse of that
there's also something more abstract
like edges to shoes and shoes to edges
or uh translate between zebras and
horses
one thing that's different about this
approach compared to the other approach
um the kind of the domain adversarial
training is that here we actually don't
even need any labeled examples from our
source data set in order to train for
these mappings the
this is kind of a purely an unsupervised
approach for mapping between two domains
um so the original paper for this didn't
actually use it for domain adaptation
they just used it to kind of generate
pictures like this
uh but you can actually use it for
domain adaptation
so
um one place where it was used was it
was used to translate between simulated
robots and real robots
uh and so the simulate the simulation is
kind of shown on the left the real image
is shown on the right and it's able to
basically kind of generate real looking
images from simulated images and vice
versa
uh and it turns out that if you
basically train with reinforcement
learning in the simulator and actually
evaluate that policy uh on the real
robot you can get a success rate a grasp
success rate that's much higher than if
you only use some data
um and if you
um kind of used something called domain
randomization where you try to randomize
the simulator as much as possible but it
would actually try to use real data to
kind of translate between simulation and
real
you can also uh use these to kind of
translate between humans and robots so
this is approach that wanted to use data
from humans in order to improve
improve a robot policy and so the top
row here is our real images and the
bottom row are images generated by the
generative model and once you kind of
generate it in the robot domain it's a
lot easier to kind of use that data
directly
yeah
um I still have a question about cycling
how do you ensure that
something from the source domain doesn't
uh map arbitrary to something else in
the Target event so for example you're
the next two manners say synthetic dogs
and foxes and the target domain is um
real dogs and foxes what's to stop the
model from mapping synthetic dots with
real foxes and vice versa
yeah so this is a great question so one
thing it could do is it could map
um
maybe it does it does kind of obey the
cycle consistency because that's what we
trained it for and so if for example
um maybe it does actually map from
here to here and it also Maps like from
here to here but maybe this is kind of
uh kind of real dogs and this is real
foxes I think you said uh and this is uh
what's synthetic okay uh synthetic uh
foxes and this is uh synthetic
dogs
um and so first it it is possible for it
to learn this
um there are two things that can
encourage it not to learn this uh the
first is that oftentimes when people
design architectures for this they'll
encourage the architecture is to only
change the local feature the local
features of the image
and
if you encourage it to only change the
local features then it's somewhat hard
to create
a dog out of a fox like the maybe the
ears look different or something like
that
and the second thing is that um
if you have a data set that has like
maybe it's like 80 real dogs and 20 real
foxes and uh 80 synthetic dogs and 20
synthetic boxes then these sorts of day
set statistics will encourage it to
actually get the right mapping because
it will be uh
it'll be pretty difficult like
um
basically if you need to generate things
that look like the target distribution
and you are mapping 80 of your dogs to
80 boxes then that won't actually match
the target distribution
um so having these sorts of statistics
and this kind of frequency of objects in
your data set be consistent between the
source and Target can really help the
mapping
um but if you do have 80 synthetic boxes
at 80 real dogs then it may actually
learn a mapping between foxes and dogs
uh and so this is kind of getting back
to the assumption that we made with the
previous approach which is that like the
the two domains do need to have a
similar distribution in some sense
choices and design choices more than the
mathematics yeah exactly and so the um
like when I've worked with these kinds
of methods before typically we actually
are trying to when we tune the method we
actually tune the data set more than the
method
cool so
um the kind of pros of this approach is
it's conceptually pretty cool although
maybe that's not a reason to use it
um and it can actually work pretty well
uh it's also quite interpretable
this means that it gives you cool
pictures but it also means that it can
be easier to debug because if you
actually like generate like Run f with
your model and you see it's mapping dogs
to foxes
then you know what's going wrong whereas
if you just have this uh feature space
that's a little bit difficult to
interpret because it's very high
dimensional then it can be a little bit
difficult to understand what's going
wrong with your approach
um the downside is that it does involve
an adversarial optimization just like
before and it also involves generative
modeling now as well and those can be
require larger models
um and like feature alignment it does
require this sort of clear alignment in
the distributions in order to work well
cool um and then the last thing I'd like
to mention is you can actually combine
the two approaches that we just talked
about these cyclegan approach and domain
adversarial neural networks there's an
approach that basically incorporates
both of these into a single uh
approach and on things like the
character recognition tasks we looked at
you're able to do much better so uh
domain adversarial neural networks alone
gets six 73 accuracy whereas this
approach gets a 90 accuracy when
translating from street view house
numbers to amnest
um and it could also work on more
complex data so this is something where
they're trying to translate a classifier
trained on synthetic driving data to
real driving data from the cityscapes
data set and they were able to uh much
more accurately segment objects in the
scene uh in comparison to Prior domain
adaptation approaches so that's it on
domain adaptation those are really the
kind of three classes of domain
adaptation methods that have been most
successful and most popular